[Musique]
le site est superbe et depuis une
trentaine d'années il est presque oublié
à 20 km du mont tremblant l'ancienne
pisciculture de saint-faustin fermé en
1992 redeviendra une attraction dans les
laurentides
derrière moi dans le bâtiment principal
sera le point de départ de ce qu'on va
appeler c'est ce qu'on appelle le
sentier des cimes qui est une première
en amérique du nord
donc c'est avec une passerelle au niveau
de la sinne des armes va se promener le
près d'un kilomètre dans la forêt avant
d'arriver une tour d'observation qui est
à 40 mètres de hauteur qui va permettre
d'avoir une vue à 360° sur toute la
région des laurentides
les travaux sont commencés de la petite
route du village qui en a bien besoin
jusqu'à la montagne où sera construit le
projet l'ouverture est prévue pour l'été
2000 22
le promoteur une compagnie allemande a
déjà neuf sites du genre en europe et la
tour de saint-faustin ressemblera
beaucoup à celle ci située en slovénie
le sentier des cimes sera ouvert en
toute saison et on espère y accueillir
jusqu'à 400 mille visiteurs par année
on partait avec l'idée que c'est un très
très gros projet peut-être un peu même
envahissant départ finalement s'est
rendu compte que ça demeure très
paisible et très silencieux
ce ça nous a beaucoup plu parce que ça
vient vraiment c'est vraiment en accord
avec les activités que nous emmène
ariane paris le gall a visité deux des
sites européens pour se préparer son
entreprise qui vont des produits de la
forêt est déjà installée sur le terrain
de la pisciculture le contact avec la
nature c'est beaucoup plus que
simplement se se promener parmi les
armes c'est comprendre notre
environnement
et puis basta on a la ferme intention
d'y contribuer par l'éducation en
donnant des ateliers gratuits aux gens
qui vont venir ce sera donc une nouvelle
attraction touristique pour les
laurentides de plus en plus visités mont
tremblant accueille trois millions de
touristes par année
la piste du petit train du nord qui
passe juste à côté du futur sont il
estime pas vu son achalandage augmenter
de 40% en 2020
c'est sûr les écoliers dans tout ça mais
on sent cet engouement
l'ope il accroissant sa popularité sur
tous les réseaux à toutes les régions de
notre territoire
des chantiers qui était entré perdu
devient soudainement populaire de façon
exponentielle
mais la région continuent à se
privatiser condos et résidences de luxe
pousse partout et les accès publics à la
nature deviennent plus rares
le sentier des cimes et bien accueilli
par les résidents que nous avons
rencontré mon temps pour diversifier ce
serait vraiment bien des développeurs
qui vont prendre toutes nos endroits
vert pour faire des progrès et
développement
ça se passe partout c'est choquant ont
été installés c'est facile de dire on
veut pas que les autres viennent un peu
grise la mrc des laurentides se prépare
aussi à relancer le parc est qu un
immense territoire public grand comme
deux mille cinq cents terrains de
football
également situé à saint faustin on y
trouve quatre lacs leurs passerelles
aquatique devenus vétustes doivent être
reconstruites
il ya très peu de plans d'eau
accessibles actuellement sont
effectivement les propriétaires
riverains qui s'approprie de justement
des même s'ils sont nombreux des lacs de
la région et va évidemment on essaie de
donner accès à ces plans d'eau là le
parc eco offre déjà un camping plusieurs
sentiers de randonnée et 20 refuge
perché où c'est possible de dormir à
l'année mais cet espace plus reculés
demeure encore méconnu la mrc veulent
exploiter davantage et là des projets
pour les cinq prochaines années ça peut
être des habitations sur l'eau
actuellement à des habitations dans les
arts ça peut être un autre type de
camping ça peut être initiation à la
pêche ça peut être également
une cabane à ce nouveau genre 4 millions
de dollars devront être investis et
québec sera sollicité les laurentides
offriront donc de nouveau accès au lac
et à la forêt québécoise c'est tout
quand on est la cour arrière de montréal
ici jean cbc que si radio-canada saint
faustin lac carré
[Musique]